On behalf of our native country
I have said
that she is our favourite opponent
in the ski tracks.
You're kind of from the forest yourself.
You're born and raised in Lillehammer.
Yes, the forest and the mountains.
The Birkebeiner race over the mountain.
Yes, I go skiing a lot.
It's what I love to do the most.
-How extreme are you?
-Well, no, I'm...
No, I'm rather a harmonious skier,
that's what I've become over the years.
I do it to get some peace of mind.
I've wondered what it is.
I think it's that you follow tracks
and you can't go wherever you want to.
But then your mind can wander.
So I have solved
personal problems and book problems.
"What should I name this chapter?"
I solve my life problems while skiing.
We're going to talk
about something more serious.
Your bestseller "One Of Us" is about
Anders Behring Breivik and his victims.
It has got international attention.
This week Åsne followed him
in court once again.
It is a national trauma,
we're mourning...
-You didn't speak to him for this book.
-He wrote to say he didn't want to.
This factors all together
not one dramatic answer.
His childhood is probably
what he lies about the most.
He has a long story of rejections
in his life.
He was one of us.
Anders Behring Breivik has sued
the Norwegian government
because of inhuman prison conditions.
You're covering the trial
for international press agencies.
How was it for you? You followed
the first trial for ten weeks.
How was it to see him again?
You've come straight from the court.
I was ambivalent about going there.
I hadn't planned to go.
But it was happening here again,
and I thought: "I'll follow this case."
All the journalists were anxious.
We hadn't seen him for four years.
"How has he changed?"
But when we saw him,
he turned out to be exactly the same.
He certainly didn't have
any isolation damages.
He was himself, but even more
absorbed in his political project.
What he wants is a stage,
a place to share his thoughts
and spread his message.
And to gain more supporters.
That became very clear this week.
So it's mostly attention
he wants to get from this?
That was very clear.
His case fell apart this week.
It's obvious that the government
will win this round.
When he was asked about
his alleged isolation damages,
he had to search for the words.
He mentioned headaches
and being a bit depressed now and then.
He couldn't even
come up with something
which could have been a result
of being in isolation for so long.
He is someone who sought isolation
before the terror attack.
He's not a very social person.
Reports by doctors and psychiatrists
were presented in court.
According to them, he had said in prison
that he had never been happier.
He was very pleased
with his three cells.
So he is quite happy.
This was his only way to be heard.
That's why he sued the government.
When you sit there... There are
journalists there and yourself.
What's the atmosphere like?
Do people feel provoked?
At times. He had three hours
were he could speak freely.
I've got to know him a little bit
while working on the book for two years
and spending ten weeks in court.
You get used to the way he speaks.
After three hours you've had enough.
And I thought: "Can someone
just turn off the microphone?"
Nobody does that of course.
He's allowed to be heard.
But he's very manipulative
towards his own team and the judge.
He wants to talk about things
that don't relate to the case.
He went straight on to politics.
The judge let him speak.
I guess it was to get
a clearer picture of
how he is
when he is allowed to speak freely
to get an understanding of
whether he has been damaged.
You called him manipulative,
but who is being manipulated?
He manipulates situations a lot.
He gets his way in the end.
Are we manipulated as well?
The media? We're talking about him.
To a certain degree, but I think
the media has been responsible
both in the first trial
and this second one.
Little has been written
about him in between.
There's been a lot the last few days.
Next week there will be less.
We can't think: "It's unwise
to report the worst things he says."
Those things expose him.
He can't differentiate between
what's important and not.
He can't put it into context
with the crimes he has committed.
He talks about plastic cutlery
as a torture like existence,
or about cold coffee and waiting
20 minutes before being let out.
Like it's bad room service at a hotel.
He's not able to judge what...
He's not able to read social cues.
That's where he fails in a court.
But he will always try
to use the situation
to get the best place
or to get you to listen one more hour.
That's also something I noticed
in the letters I received.
-You got letters from him?
-Yes. I asked for an interview thinking:
"Is it right to interview him?"
Yes, it's a book about him.
He wrote back: "Dear Åsne..."
and was very flattering.
"But I see you as a predator.
You will stab me harder than others."
"But I can work with you..."
There were lots of "buts".
"...if I get to write half the book."
He would do the middle and I the rest.
-Then he would give an interview.
-He wanted to co-write it.
Has he read your book?
He sent me a handwritten letter:
"Could you please send me a copy?"
It was strange, because when
I was writing it I was thinking:
"He is bloody well going to read this."
About the people he killed.
About the innocent youths
he didn't even know who were.
However, when the book was finished,
I really didn't want him to read it.
So I never sent him a copy,
but I assume his solicitor got him one.
Some researchers were meeting him
and his condition was
that Åsne Seierstad's name
and the book were never mentioned.
Then I knew he had read it
and had not liked what he read.
His mother, who is no longer alive,
you met her for your book.
You were one of few who met her,
right before she died.
She was mentioned again
in this trial as well,
things that he had said
about his mother.
Did they have
the same understanding of reality?
They have a very strange relationship,
which they have had all their lives.
She is the one who was responsible
for him being neglected as a child
which caused him damage early on.
This has been documented.
Love and hate. "I wish you were dead."
Then she's cuddling him in bed.
Later in life the power balance turns.
Now he has the power.
He tells her not to walk next to him,
fearing he'll be seen as mentally ill.
"Don't stand so close to me, mum."
She told me this is what he said.
When I met her
she only had one week left of her life.
She knew that. I believe she wished
to make sort of a testament.
She said she felt that Norwegians
should forgive him, like she had done.
I thought:
"She's got no right to say that."
He's never asked for forgiveness
or shown remorse.
She also told me about his childhood,
the reality she wanted to portray,
things that also had been good.
In the trial he said he hoped
she wouldn't be called as a witness.
He said his mother is his Achilles heel.
There is something that she knows.
He also refused to see her
right before she died
because she wasn't proud enough
of what he had done.
I don't think we will ever
get to the bottom of that relationship.
He wrote nasty things
about his mother in the "manifesto".
I believe this love/hate relationship
lasted their whole lives.
At the same time she's the one
who knows him the best.
Åsne, thank you very much for coming.
I'd like you to stay.
We have more guests. Thank you.